I've released your friend from a
terrible burden I love him as you do
because you do and was trigons blessing
he's part of the family now
Oh Rachel it feels so good to be home
you'll see they'll all see
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie so we gotta
talk about Titan season 2 Superboy
Krypto Cadmus labs and Trigon in that
Batman scene that they ended on well do
new round of that flash ring giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Superboy moment on the video it could be
any version of Superboy although most
people know Conner Kent as Superboy
so in the episode with Trigon breaking
Robin sort of explaining what was going
on with Batman the actors that actually
play Batman in that scene came out
afterwards because they were stunt
people because he never takes the mask
off so you never actually see his face
you just see him in the Batman costume
so the actual Batman that we saw during
the episode is based on Robins memories
or Nightwing's memories of him so he is
the real version of Batman but this was
all created in his head so the real
Batman is probably in Gotham or on
Justice League business not knowing
what's going on with Trigon although you
have to imagine that there are a lot of
metas a lot of magically inclined people
like Constantine or Satana that would
probably recognize when another magical
being of trigons power entered our
dimension so people are probably
starting to find out what's going on
this growing darkness coming from Trigon
in the way he does it is by breaking
these people and making them
quote-unquote part of his family like
Dick Grayson says his whole thing at the
end of season 1 is that he can't eat the
world until he breaks Raven because
Raven is the only person that can stop
him and now it seems like that's what
the arc of season 2 or maybe they'll
even push it to season 3 depending on
how they want to pull the taffy on this
so they're doing some things way faster
than I ever expected like bringing
Trigon to this world and they're doing
some things a little bit slower like I
would have expected they they would just
put him in his Nightwing costume at the
end of this season but right now at the
pace that they're going it seems like
that's gonna be the end of season 2 like
they didn't even bring the team together
in the traditional way not everybody got
their costume so the beginning of season
2 will be them saving Dick Grayson but
also this big scene with Connor Kent so
he's one of those characters that just
like Raven you not really sure which way
they're gonna go because of his evil
half quote-unquote so I do kind of
understand why they decided to choose
him as like the next big character that
they did because there's so many Teen
Titans care
I'm assuming they have free rein of
pretty much anyone they want if we just
got Manu Bennett and then his son during
that big crossover in the destro costume
in Titans can do Deathstroke whenever
they want and recast the character it's
pretty easy for them to do whichever big
character you want them to do and the
way they do the a-list characters
remains to be seen because they
reference a lot of Wonder Woman stuff I
had a big theory that they were gonna
wait to do a lot of Superman stuff till
they introduced potential Conner Kent in
surprise surprise they just did so we
got a couple Superman name drops in the
finale I think you know next season when
he's actually interacting with the other
characters they'll start to refer to the
real Superman within this world and I
don't think that it's gonna be Tyler
hoechlin
I know there are a lot of questions
about like next year's the big crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover in the DC TV
universe and they just started doing all
this Tricon stuff I think that the
Titans universe is mostly gonna be
revolving around this overarching trigon
arc because Doom Patrol is getting ready
to start that's happening concurrently
with what's happening on Titans right
now so they'll probably build up to
their own crossover you know but never
say never I mean they could potentially
crossover with the other CW DC TV shows
don't worry about that right now the
scenic Cadmus starts with him breaking
containment and you'll notice that it
says subject 13 that's originally what
he was called like they didn't call him
Conner Kent till much later in the
comics the reason why he's called
subject 13 is because he's Cadmus labs
13th attempt to clone Superman they were
trying to create their own Superman so
that they could exploit him Cadmus labs
hasn't always been an evil organization
but they're a little more morally
ambiguous than STAR Labs mostly STAR
Labs has been popping up in flash titles
so they tend to be more good people
Cadmus tends to be more of a gray area
so Cadmus labs has this secret project
this Superman doesn't know about they've
stolen DNA from him for their project
and they just keep trying they get to
number 13 Lex Luthor finds out about the
project and hijacks it for his own
purposes without telling the other
scientists at Cadmus because he's just
so powerful he has information about
what's going on Cadmus had found out
that if they spliced Superman's DNA with
the humans they could make a clone that
was a little more controllable because
their attempts at straight-up cloning
him making like a hundred percent second
Superman
just didn't work so by making him half
human the project became more successful
when Lex Luthor found this out
he actually swapped the human DNA that
they were using for it for his own so
that Superboy would be half Lex Luthor
and he could embed special mental
triggers into Superboy's mind that would
allow him to take over and use him for
his own nefarious purposes later so he
would basically become Lex Luthor's
finger puppet at a time of his choosing
they actually did this much later in the
comics and initially when Superboy
debuted for the first time it was at the
beginning of the reign of the Superman
arc right after the death of Superman in
the comics nobody knew anything about
the Lex Luthor plot that became a retcon
later on he was just half-human
his powers worked a little bit
differently too because of the cloning
process so in order to duplicate
Superman's powers he would actually
generate a telekinetic field that would
give him the ability to fly it would
give him his invulnerability his
super-strength
pretty much everything from a visual
perspective that would identify him as
something related to Superman like oh he
could fly he can lift stuff he's like
the Man of Steel he's about half as
powerful as Superman but he only has
half of Superman's weakness to
kryptonite which is why later in this
teaser he's able to rip the Kryptonite
door off of kryptos cell so obviously
the second big thing that they have in
here is Krypto the Superdog or possibly
a clone of him so it's not really clear
why they have Krypto the Superdog
without Superman knowing about it like I
feel like Superman would know if Krypto
was on earth but that's the reason why
his eyes glow red when he rips the door
off because it's meant to let you know
that the Kryptonite isn't dampening his
powers anymore and it confirm exactly
who it is if you didn't watch Young
Justice on that TV show Conner Kent had
a friend that was a giant white wolf but
that was not Krypto this is very clearly
meant to be Krypto like that's why they
want to confirm who he is my early
theory about why they're doing Krypto
the Superdog is just to balance out
Superboy's more rage like nature he's
sort of like the Hulk like he just goes
crazy on everyone if you've ever watched
an episode of Young Justice with
Superboy that lets you know exactly what
he's like imagine the world's angriest
teenager with super-strength and part of
Superman's abilities so because of a
character is like that all the time it
can get a little annoying so you need
something to balance them out and calm
them down to make them feel
a little more identifiable like oh he's
not a total psychopath and that's
probably where the dog comes in so they
opened the teaser with him just hulking
out on all these scientists looking like
he's killing some of them but then he
frees the dog from captivity so it's
like oh he's not all bad like he
actually does care about some things so
he's not gonna be walking around just
killing people like a terminator all
season long so season 2 picks up the
producer said that the Titans will have
to come together as a team to save Dick
Grayson then they'll have to fight
Trigon that'll mostly be Ravens battle
but we're supposed to get an entire
season of Seamus Deaver as Trigon so you
know he just showed up at the end of the
season for a little while obviously he's
such a huge character what'll probably
happen is is that the Titans in their
quest to save Robin and stop Trigon will
run into Superboy and then you get into
more Justice League stuff I don't know
exactly how much Donna Troy we're gonna
get in season two I don't know if she's
gonna be a main character but I do think
that she'll be in more episodes than she
was in during season one so big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
which of the next big characters you
want them to introduce during season two
in right now I think there was a rumor
that they're gonna start shooting season
two in February meaning that they would
be able to start airing episodes in
October again so it sounds like the
schedule for Titans will be the same as
it was during season one there's a whole
bunch more stuff happening I need to do
another Aquaman video but leave your
requests in the comments below there's
like a lot of really big stuff happening
before the end of the year
click here for my non-spoilery aquaman
review and click here for that brand new
men in black Chris Hemsworth trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight